vu de l'extérieur ce cube n'a l'air de
rien qu'est ce que c'est
vu de l'intérieur c'est autre chose mais
un miroir infinie une explosion de
lumières des miroirs dans toute la pièce
qui réflète l'image à l'infini il faut
voir chaque lumière comme une âme qui
flotte dans l'univers et dans cette
expérience d'être entouré de ses
lumières parce que peut-être un jour
nous autres aussi on va arriver là avec
les autres
l'autre à la voici à tokyo celle qui
nous donne cette expérience yayoi kusama
et leur à 89 ans le 22 mars et elle est
toujours aussi active travaille dans son
atelier tous les jours le soir venu
yayou et kusama traverse la rue pour se
rendre là où elle habite depuis plus de
40 ans dans un hôpital psychiatrique
c'est son choix d'être dans un hôpital
elle qui souffre depuis toujours de
crises d'anxiété d'hallucinations
donc c'est la fin de l'exposition elle
s'appelle au buteur et chiens sales
d'oblitération une salle remplie de
poids de couleurs qui en sera
complètement tapissé d'ici la fin de
l'exposition
parce que c'est le public qui appose
c'est colin fournies par le musée yayi
kusama affectionne particulièrement les
pois c'est vraiment un symbole universel
pour l'énergie de la vie le soleil la
lune les étoiles donc toute la nature
qui on a des symboles qui sont des
formes qui sont rondes
elle vient de loin né en 29 dans le
japon rural
il ya aussi kusama et d'une famille
bourgeoise avec des parents qui ne
pensent qu'à la mariée alors qu'elle
elle veut peindre faut le faire elle
quitte le japon et en 57 s'installe à
new york
et là elle va s'éclater ja oui kusama
expérimentant tous ses new york les
années 60 elle réalise un film dans
lequel elle joue des poids il y en a
partout y compris sur les mines ou les
sixties tout le monde tout nu à wall
street devant la statue de la liberté
il ya un hic ozama organise des
événements choc qui prône notamment la
libération sexuelle
cette idée d'enlever toute forme
d'identité et devenir ego d'allemands
donc on est toutes le même donc est ce
lié à cette idée de être avec l'univers
avec la nature avec des choses qui sont
plus son plus grand camion mais la vie à
new york use et il ya aussi kusama a
toujours des problèmes de santé mentale
comme le relève ce documentaire d'amd
et nous j'ai fait de nombreuses
tentatives de suicide quand j'étais à
new york et j'ai souvent séjourné à
l'hôpital elle retourne au japon à 73 et
tombe à peu près dans l'oubli partageant
son temps entre l'atelier et
l'hospitalisation volontaire ça prendra
sa participation à la biennale de venise
vingt ans plus tard pour qu on la
redécouvre ses oeuvres sous des font
l'objet d'expositions dans les grands
musées tellement de bourbourg momar ses
services pour illustrer la chanson love
thorn et même la maison vuitton
s'associer à l'artiste japonaise pour
des collections avec ses célèbres poids
pendant ce temps yayoi kusama n'arrête
pas de travailler par exemple
l'exposition au musée des beaux-arts de
l'ontario nous montre quelques toiles
qui font partie de la série mon âme
éternel commencé en 2009
il devait y en avoir une centaine
d'artistes en a créé plus de 500 et ça
continue
elle a besoin il a besoin de ça ça lui
permet de vivre et aussi de continuer à
être partout où elle passe l'exposition
kusama fait fureur les billets se
vendent par internet en quelques minutes
il y à l'expo toronto 6 installations
fermées avec miroir et à cause du nombre
élevé de visiteurs
écoutez bien ceci le temps de visite
d'une installation sera limitée à 4
personnes en même temps pour 20 secondes
chrono pour visiter l'exposition toronto
c'est à peu près complet vous pouvez
toujours tenter votre chance ensuite à
cleveland et atlanta pour voir les
oeuvres de l'artiste étoiles de 88 ans
qui fait courir les foules
[Musique]